[Music]
hi I'm Toby and welcome to another
episode of the joys of mathematics if
this is your first time watching then
here's your chance to go and grab a
notepad and pen so you can work along at
home and if you are a returned viewer
thanks for coming back now today we're
going to work through something that's a
little more abstract in its creation and
we're going to do this to hopefully see
that sometimes you can't always trust
something on its first impression
sometimes you need to look a little bit
closer because often things are not as
they seem
so keep in mind that this piece today is
going to be more of an abstract artwork
than a conventional one so I've got my
trusty titanium white color here and
let's get started
the first thing that we're going to do
is we're going to let a equal B a and B
are our first two characters and they
are variables they could be anything
that they ever wanted to be they have
the whole world as their oyster but
today a and B have chosen to be exactly
the same thing now as we go along don't
be afraid of the mathematics here I'm
here with you and I'm going to help you
go through it well what we're going to
do is times both sides by B that will
give us a times b is equal to b times
itself b squared so we've added a couple
of happy little B's here to this line we
added these to both sides so that's fine
we can add or multiply whatever we want
as long as we do it on each side same
with division and subtraction there's a
moral of the story here only do to
others what you want done to yourself
and when you've got two sides of an
equation anything you do to one side you
have to do to the other now let's add
some more happy little B's and in fact
we're going to add another B squared to
each side of this equation
all right got a lot of happy little bees
let's just simplify this B squared plus
B squared
could just be written as 2 B squared and
this line for the side says the same now
you might be sort of wondering how this
is going to end up anywhere but just
trust me sometimes you need to just go
where the wind blows you and it is
pretty windy out here in the garden
today I hope that it doesn't cause too
many issues but let's just follow along
for the drift of the wind here and you
might have to trust me a little bit okay
we've added B squared what if we do
we'll put an A B what if we subtract the
same term from both sides and that term
is going to be to a B all right let's do
it to both sides this term that I
subtracted from both sides could have
been literally anything since I did it
to both sides and it's going to make the
result the same but up until now we
haven't done anything illegal without
algebra this is all this is all fine
okay so if we have one a B and we're
taking away to a B's how many a B's do
we have left well the answer is we'll
still have our B squared and minus one a
B and on the side we've got to be
squared minus 2 a B all right what I
want to do next is to factorize this
line and I'm going to continue up here
to do that so there's one common term to
both sides and that is B squared minus a
B on this side we could take a 1 out of
the bracket if we really wanted to
somewhat unnecessary but we have 1 times
B squared minus a B and that is equal to
well we can take a 2 outside the
brackets now to
times b-squared minus a B getting a
little close to the edge there but I
think we're alright okay so now we've
got the slide still nothing illegal has
happened we want to check my algebraic
you can go through there but now we have
something all right we have B squared
minus a B on both sides of the equation
what mean we may want to do is to
recognize that if we divide both sides
by the same thing that's alright like we
can divide both sides by B squared minus
a B and that would be the same as
cancelling out this term if we'd
cancelled out this term in brackets then
what we have left with is that one is
equal to two now here's where it appears
to be pretty abstract and in fact
something doesn't quite add up here I'm
going to put a little box of shame
around this because this means we've
done something weird or something
illegal a long way we can't just
suddenly have one being equal to two
because that would fundamentally change
so many things about mathematics we rely
on two being exactly double one and not
being equal to each other so have a
little look at the algebra and see if
you can identify where we went wrong and
why don't worry if you can't get it I'm
going to show you in just a second but
if you've formed your opinion and then
let's have a look I stand by that all of
this algebra is correct
the issue comes in at this line here now
we divided both sides by B squared minus
a B and that would be fine as long as B
squared minus a B the stuff in brackets
was not equal to zero if this stuff was
equal to zero this would amount to
dividing both sides by zero and as you
might know dividing by zero is kind of
forbidden and mathematics the answer to
that is undefined when you start to
viding by zero things in the universe
stop making much sense
you could already sort of argue that the
world doesn't make a lot of sense to us
you know good things happen to bad
people all the time and there's a lot of
things that are unexplained but right
here this would give us some weird
things dividing by zero leads to all
sorts of things such as that one is
equal to two and frankly this is
nonsense so we need to sort this out so
let's have a look B squared since a and
B are equal to each other is actually
the same as a times B so this in
brackets is in fact equal to zero and
what we have on this line up here is
that one times zero is equal to two
times zero now I mean sure anything
times zero is going to be equal to zero
so these 1 and two could have been
replaced by literally anything all this
really shows is that zero is equal to
zero so if we've proved anything that's
what we've proved here not that one is
equal to two so there is a bit of a
moral here and it was to not trust your
first impressions all the time you know
when we did this step it might have
looked like it was legal and this might
have looked like a legal result but we
used our sort of critical thinking we
realized it probably doesn't make sense
and there's probably a reason why so the
rule for mathematics is that whenever
you're going to divide by something
check that that something is not zero
but also in life you know sometimes
things are too good or too weird to be
true so always look a little closer and
don't just take things at face value now
I'm going to rub this off here and make
room for a little message a duster can
get pretty chalky so you just eat the
devil out of it this episode of the joys
of mathematics is what hereby Skillshare
Skillshare are an online learning
community with classes and things like
business design and technology I'm
currently working through some courses
on writing short stories and editing
videos and final cut if you want to
learn new skills then as a special offer
for my viewers
first 500 people to sign up for
Skillshare at the link in the
description will get two months of
unlimited access for free that's access
to over 20,000 courses so I'm sure you
can find one there that you like this is
also your personal invitation to
subscribe to my channel for more videos
like this don't forget to take a closer
look at the world around you and from
the bottom of my heart I hope that you
have an absolutely mathematical day
here's some bonus after the credits
footage but I just wanted to show you
guys something in the garden it's over
here and it's a moth or a butterfly
perched on a little branch there now
that's pretty nice but don't look too
close past him well you might see what
scared me earlier it seems to be a
spider I'll zoom in because I don't want
to get too close it's either the spider
or like the skin of the spider but to be
honest I didn't know that spiders head
skin so I'm getting out of here
[Music]